no you shut up
oh hello I'm Adam McLaughlin from wacky
gamer I'm gonna be sick
did you know that I have an online
puppet show called Animal trash that you
can watch on YouTube it's true we even
made a video for Vsauce but don't take
my word for it
check it out won't you check it out
won't you when I think of disgusting
redheaded monsters with skin conditions
the first person I think of is Danny
Bonaduce then I think of the ginger
topped Beast
no not carrot top Blanca from street
fighter first and foremost I do want to
address the Beast comment I mean really
Blanc is so ugly he's like the redheaded
stepson of the fighting universe I
wonder what it was like for him growing
up of course I was picked on in high
school I look like an Incredible Hulk
Mark McGwire I've heard all the insults
prehistoric carrot top
Firebug of Guatemala child molester
Pokemon zombie carrot cake I've heard
them all that's the kind of childhood
trauma you never recover from do you
think it's been easy for Blanca it's a
wonder I went to rehab usually when a
monster Zsasz uglies Blanca they have
some kind of superpower that makes up
for their appearance like The Incredible
Hulk strength all Blanca has is some
really unreliable static electricity
does anyone ever like wait wait wait I
got it
damnit no my B button stock and to add
insult to injury the only way to use
Blancas lightning attack is to let your
opponent get close enough to punch you
in the face this is my life despite its
numerous shortcomings I find myself
really liking Blanca and whenever I play
them I can't help but wonder what's he
going to do after Street Fighter where I
go after super street fighter fall
arby's hadouken fire bow hey Vsauce
Michael here and I hope you had fun
watching Animalia trash Adams actually
made way more than what you just saw so
to see more check out animal trash on
YouTube and while you're at it help
wacky gamer celebrate 1 million views
you can do that by clicking right here